[Music]
Let me feel you.
What felt
different? What felt different? A lot
more tension in the second. Okay, good.
Lot more tension.
Lot more
tension. Okay.
Come
on. Lot of
tension. Feel
you. A lot of
trickery. Trickery.
You feel the thumb lock just here.
Thumb
lock just here.
Then the tension came
right. Whoa.
Let's I don't know what this will feel
like, but come over here. I'm used to
you.
And then you're going to uh do the
technique. You're going to try to just
keep a fingertip on my hand. Okay. I I
should be able to do it. Okay.
And notice how
light not like
that is extremely
light. Okay? And you can feel the
lightness now. There's that tension
and then the
lightness. Notice the
difference. Tension. You're already
going
out. You're coming in.
Look how long it takes for you to go
out. Do you see that? So that where's
that energy
going? If you're still coming towards me
and you're not going out, where's that
energy going? Do Yeah. It's going down.
Do you get it? And so when you're here
and you're It's not coming in. I don't
want it to come in.
The more you
push. Right. Right. I don't need to be
worried about it. I don't need to be
worried about it. Okay.
So, I let it come in, but I stay relaxed
here. Okay. And there'll be more energy
bouncing out then. Okay. Try it.